hello and welcome to this video playing
Arwen with black and we get what Sony
messiaen would be case so let's see what
he is going to do and play for this f5
setup you have like a Texas center he
immediately tries to make some use of
this each six night for example if he
takes my night is gets into the plane
yeah this is the more frequent choice I
think this night f7 is usual Bishop g5
here doesn't go any much so I go back
now
h4 has been played against me which is a
mistake um because it's 865 so let's go
d5 here right that's the idea I guess
let's see eight Bishop is a little bit
off but sometimes it can sneak in via a6
and and so on so Knight to c4 I think I
think I go here it has no future on c8
anyway and at least in some cases I'm
able to take I don't know queen edge
file maybe I should've played g4 first
yeah I think I don't want to take I mean
if I take wait if I take Queen and Queen
85 that's awkward when Queen see one
maybe
that's not particularly clear Quincy
wanna complain but now I have Bishop h6
there so I think I might threaten okay
we just doesn't care what I do that so
night a form
yeah I think we need form I just go
clean edge for him I mean I have have
this space advantage on the kingside 95
I will hack on c4 play up th root d8 I
don't know maybe I can actually save
time I don't think so
let's kind of this first I mean my ideas
f4 95 f3 and mate this kind of things
did it it's a bit case management yeah
so he wants to just trade trade trade
trade now it's definitely definitely an
I don't want to trade he wants to make a
draw this is the whole idea making it
all
and maybe I can sacrifice it I don't
want to make a drawers the problem
it's that a way to continue 97a various
ways to seek the exchange of course I
know it plays for win on some okay
it mean it's perfectly reasonable to try
f43 is my idea maybe I should have
played membership afraid baby deepening
the night maybe yes I will had a good
move
unfortunately that is a good move
Haywood you won't take okay
now now taking me now we have to take
and threatening night at 3:00 and I
don't think Bishop g3 makes any sense
yeah I mean f53 is dangerous I think
you're probably playing no no
going back here to have f4 again yeah
but now I'm not trading I can take here
actually no I'm not trading at all
just keep stuff on the board will double
on the F file if I was hanging also
time warning I'm overlooking the super
simple moves here what is this stuff I
mean white was already completely busted
and now I'm sitting in this stuff it's
really really terrible
I get sometimes so close myself
check check check check check check
check check check check extremely low
what it's time for but it's enough I
really I really miss stuff you have for
sure so we got into this complicated
middle game as is typical for the
segregation and yeah I think all this
makes sense and from both sides so that
is not like by the engine
96 yeah yeah I probably have to take em
I mean on a good day something like that
could work but that is a problem
Aaron says you were lost
yeah maybe but you were also lost so
yeah he started to play for win
and yeah probably this isn't all that
grade yeah all this is like by for white
by the computer yeah maybe this Queen h4
really is something that that I should
improve upon I mean I also have to hit
the CAPTCHA here in this after which
Queen c1 probably on 94 doesn't look so
convincing here taking in d6 okay yeah
their widest pattern yeah here I was
really very optimistic I was thinking
that it must be better for me my
computer doesn't agree at all actually
yeah I just missed all this stuff it's
really really bad I should probably take
only five and B equal this is this is
this is also equal yeah it's right to
play for the for the break three and now
we have two two two two to watch out for
it here I'm breaking through
so we can check me and then we'll create
a well okay this is this is equal
pointing to the comp but I would be
fairly optimistic to win that and it's
game not not easy okay guys thanks for
watching